hi I'm Ken oh and this is my recipe for
a chocolate ripple cheesecake this
recipe was a journey this is not a poor
so here's where trouble is right now so
this recipe took a lot of development to
nail down I mean the amount of math and
science figuring out volume of batter I
needed for the whole cake what I'm going
to do is plot my calculator and figure
out within my two cups of chocolate
amongst four bowls and divided so
properly scale up as well as how much
stabilizer I needed in order for the
colors to not bleed into each other Oh
to talk
the simplest way to approach this recipe
is I wanted to make one mother batter
for every color of a cheesecake and then
divide it into four different bowls that
way each bowl got its own quantity of
chocolate to create a different tone of
brown I feel like these are almost too
close in color so maybe just a little
bit more it's gonna be very
distinguished part of the Lizzie was
just mechanics of filming while cooking
because when I would put down a bowl to
change camera lenses
the batter is hope it actually starts to
set so the idea is to like pour them all
into the pan this is not a poor
microwave it but yeah so I'll put it
into a container great yeah solutions by
area so each batter has to remain kind
of loose and warm up until it's all done
and then it can go into the fridge and
set so a tip that I learned was while
making this cheesecake at any point you
have to stop or take a break microwave
the batter for 20 seconds or so just to
get a reef Luud before you start pouring
and wait until you have a windows time
support all four colors before you do it
is if you pour layer one and then take a
break and then try to pour layer - it's
not gonna push out and you're not going
to get a nice beautiful even ring so it
definitely requires your full attention
while making fingers crossed for Landry
I'm sleep ready really pretty
living like the twilight zone right now
you did
this cheesecake is definitely one of the
more aspirational desserts I've made it
requires a lot of attention to detail
and patience so if you are a hoppy Baker
and you just want to like dedicate an
afternoon to making something like
really stunning and beautiful for your
friends or family for any occasion this
is definitely a fun recipe to like take
on as a challenge I really have a
genuine interest of knowing what other
flavors can be made of this cheesecake
so if you do make another flavor please
let us know pop in the comments and
maybe I'll give it a try too
oh I think it mango would be good
[Music]